muss jetzt schnell jonas venschott idee
will holt je länger desto mehr draußen
illegal listen das so mittel sind sich
eine besonders freut es mir jetzt auch
okay dass sie die tröte schätzen aber
noch nicht mitnehmen
da
er holt sie schaut die machen im trailer
feindlichen mächten sportlern sich je
nach dem schulabschluss ganz bitter es
ist eben nicht drin
jetzt haben sozusagen mit basco es geht
man am besten aus sportdirektor miroslav
stevic
da sich jetzt voll moment
die kommission
bei opel brauchen
ich bin froh sie sehen ja wohl nicht
mehr mit
macht sinn da schon länger na ja wieso
wenn sie zu wenig geld sind oder was ist
mit meiner leistung morgenpost aber
dieser fliegt statement gab so die
überproduktion und der überkonsum wo wir
momentan draußen und dazwischen kontroll
das paradies mit anderen landet häufig
ist es was mich aber jetzt noch mal
gefühlte bedrohung des parat
[Musik]
als teenager ist margit schneider zum
schluss gekommen dass die klimaerwärmung
das größte problem der menschheit sei
während andere party machten gründete
sie mit 16 jahren eine partei und ordnet
ihr leben seither den bedürfnissen der
umwelt unter wie die 25-jährige durch
verzicht die welt retten will
davon handelt dieser film
wir kämpfen sie persönlich den
klimawandel
es gibt jedem aus dem haus grund in
sachen mobilität und ernährung und
mobilität wird der weg von der politik
kann ich nach gut wie aus
es gibt eine außenposition kober demmin
wird entsprechend ist der nähe und liebe
landwirtschaft das große verursachen
ein zentraler punkt ohne das tor setzte
eric schneider kauft keine tierischen
produkte und fliegt nicht
kreider übernimmt sie von freunden die
letzten schuhe trug sie so lange bis
sich der fuß entzündete
[Musik]
das ist schon da
energy drink
die dosis koffein der zum ein langer tag
noch einmal für ein paar stunden länger
machen ist überrascht mich jetzt
überrascht wie yasemin jung mal zehn
wirklich sagen zu sehen mit korrekter
entsorgung jährige trank bei den
kadetten geben natur eric schneider ist
seit fünf uhr morgens unterwegs
für rund 3000 franken monatslohn
arbeitet sie als geschäftsleiterin eines
vereins der sich für alle empfindsamen
lebewesen einsetzt besonders am herzen
liegen die hühner ihre freizeit dort
vertiefe die grüne partei muster vor
einer nachts gehen sie selten zu bett es
ist freitagabend und zum festmahl mit
den geretteten peperoni kommt besuch
[Musik]
jüngere schwester pia die schwestern
stehen sich nahe auch wenn sie sich über
die vorstellungen was ein gutes leben
ausmacht nicht einig sind
das heißt er genießbar wo sie muss ein
container abklopfen die kontakt ja post
schwerin wird die rallye heiß und so
dass ich nicht so wahnsinnig viel dank
zu ägypten an schöne punkte aber er ist
doch gar keine milchprodukte sind
container ist das prinzipiell alles will
wahrscheinlich mit gott mit der familie
produkt um das dass ich mit noch knapp
noch steigern und ein fast einer
konventionellen sprit verbrannt und
alles was verbrannt wird das ressourcen
ich jetzt für wetter und verbessertes
weniger konsumieren
ich war schlussendlich ökologisch
absolut sinnvoll verteilen so empfunden
ihrer show auf
manchmal wundert sich bier über ihre
schwester und bewundert sie gleichzeitig
von freuden aber wieder mehr ist das drk
worden
das macht sie glücklich man sie das von
sich sagen dass sie konsequent ist und
das braucht sie den frieden mit ihrer
schwester offenbar aber nicht so
konsequent lebt also ich bin immer
begonnen
grundsätzlich jeder schritt nur die
markenrechte ökologisch bewusst sich
merken
das ist schon mal mehr als die meisten
möchten das super ihrem sinn ich erwarte
ja nicht das gibt's wohl aber bin ich
total frustriert es konnte aber das
erwarte ich aber ich versuche halt macht
es mich dass wir unglücklich machen
welche machen
das ist ein zusatz wurden vom food
sharing abholt viele restaurant wo sie
in den kosovo zurück gemacht hatten dass
sie praktisch sind neue kroder und jetzt
sind die ersten buches jahr gar kein
geld für 16 monate
was für ein betrag also so viel brauche
wie ich das nicht aber wer braucht schon
wie sie es auch jetzt zum beispiel
besser gepasst
trotz ozonloch wäre schneider verzichtet
nicht auf jeden plastiksack auf den
appetit schlägt anderes was deutlich
stärker ins gewicht fällt etwa die
reiselust vieler menschen ihre schwester
zb liebt das kitesurfen reiseziel
[Musik]
straßenschlachten mal kleine kompliziert
ist
da ist ja nicht die einzige was macht
sondern sehr viele leute der schweiz
versuchen durch berlin oder gar new york
wie findet sie das natürlich die
mobilität zu holen
dass mir das holz flüge also günstig ist
dass man je nach berlin einfach mit dem
flugzeug bereits schneller und günstiger
als mit dem zug war man sich mehr ins
mark gemacht denn ich setze mir
natürlich genau die arbeits dass halter
tatsächlich fliegt der war nicht so
extrem wie danke und da wo es noch nicht
wirklich gelegen hatte ganz tief ich
sage dass politiker das müsst ihr sie
also 79
hier noch eine verabredung mit ihrem
freund matt die single heißt sie im
laden vermutlich haben sie schlechte
vorschlag welt das merkt ja ich finde
ich einfach mal etwas kühler sein jeden
mann würde sowieso gefahr laufen den
anschluss zu verlieren
denn hohe momente gibt es selten im
leben der 25 jährigen auch an
wochenenden
es ist samstag und manager arbeite für
die grünen an der börse in uster auch
einen führerausweis hat sie übrigens
nicht die personen könne das ist es vor
allem das modell der zukunft
es werden das wird automatisch die
visionäre banken too long wechsel
parkplatz und probleme
bei den grünen ist schneider seit sie 16
ist dass sie die jungpartei im zürcher
oberland gegründet hatte mittlerweile
ist sie gemeinderätin in uster morgen
sind wahlen an der wiener börse hofft
schneider letzte wähler zu gewinnen
[Musik]
zu wenig und das die runden und nach
tätig und schrieb ist im schnitt kommen
so mit ihrer forschen art hat sich mit
schneider einen namen gemacht in uster
die hoffnung nicht die quittung dafür zu
bekommen sie die grünen offenbar zeitung
[Musik]
die richter vom wahlzettel die dame vor
hart gegen sie vor der wahl liste
gestrichen schauer
was löst das bei ihnen aus ja es ist
natürlich schade aber ich weiß wie solid
gibt und ich weiß susanne also im stande
sehen gäbe wie der focus wonach
setzungen seines sakkos gemüsekonsum
andere und zwar einige radikale jeden
tag fleisch essen baut nicht dass jetzt
erst dann konnte man mit demselben raum
tatsächlich ist der server nicht ideal
fürs klima denn eine pflanzliche
ernährung braucht viel weniger
ressourcen als wenn man nutzt ihre
zuerst mit pflanzen füttern muss
eric schneider ist auf dem weg zum ruf
nach
[Musik]
der hof von sarah heilig tag ist kein
gewöhnlicher bauernbetrieb alle tiere
die auf dem hof leben werden nicht
genutzt
die pferde werden nicht geritten die
hühner müssen keine eier legen tier und
mensch leben hier vom gemüseanbau
auch die ziegen müssen rein gar nichts
und wie bei allen tieren wartet man auch
bei den schweinen bis sie eines
natürlichen todes sterben bäuerin sarah
heilig tag verzichtet aus ethischen und
ökologischen gründen auf die nutzung von
tieren
[Musik]
das ist schon ein sehr großer schritt
ein geschäft lässt sich mit den tieren
trotzdem machen im letzten jahr sind
7000 menschen für führungen auf den hof
gekommen
[Musik]
märz schneider hilft als freiwillige
hier kann sie ihren kopf lüften in die
division dass jede hofe somit die
schweiz
da kommen wir brauchen mal auf ja somit
sind wir raus ich 50 johann die auf die
tasten zu sechs waren sich schwein
vorstellte sind da aber meistens an c
quadrat schneider strebt deshalb ein
verbot der massentierhaltung an
wäre ich das gesicht wenn das ist eine
sparte wurde sehr flachen als erster
golfer waren station toba klasse besser
als jeder hund mit ihrer patenschaft hat
schneider dafür gesorgt dass wandern
nicht auf die schlachtbank kam als sie
mit zwölf monaten ihr federkleid
wechselte und in dieser zeit keine armee
legte braucht ökologischen unsinn
jetzt produzieren natürlich war dann
doch ein richtiges ich stehe hier in das
raster der kamera auf die kraft gekostet
kraft führte das kraftfutter und inputs
lincoln zentraldirektion theater als der
eigene bruder von ernähre ich mich schon
rein logisch kann dass man das überall
auf alle rote wald gemacht werden hätten
ja viel zu wenig wenn man konsolidieren
und auf den boden des kompletten unsinn
[Musik]
heute fährt die studierte
umweltwissenschaftlerin ob sie mit ihren
vorstellungen wie man die welt retten
kann nicht alleine ist
in uster ist wahltag und schneider
fürchtet dass sie selbst grünen nicht
ganz oder allzu grün ist
neu hier
zumindest ihre partei hat zugelegt
doch gibt es auch einen like für ihren
persönlichen account
ich weiß warum
wir sagen aber ich weiß ich noch nicht
und jetzt 12 pedro passos coelho zu
schwach
so ist ja sieht durch das buch sicher
sie verbrauchen die parteikollegen haben
eine feier vorbereitet
sind sie hätte ja absolut
abra schon wieder im stress
die laufen ja es gibt es zur idealen das
stimmt meint dazu machen wie massiv wird
schneider engagiert sich für eine food
sharing organisation
ich zeichne 1 prozent vor allem
politiker wäre dann weiß ich nicht so
viele dass ich das mache dass ich der
essensreste unter alles von etwa vier
tage abholen und gratis miteinander lied
verteilen
dieses marke privileg viel lauter macht
das neves coop migros macht das wirklich
meist das entspricht mega einzigartige
möglichkeit zum extrem viel des
mittelstandes reduzieren und das zu
demokratie salmi taktgebers bruch hat
und die dämpfe ihn viele für minimal
sich so wie die von debi an sieben tagen
die woche muss sie sicherstellen dass
die reste eines partner restaurants
abgeholt werden
wieder 20 km weg
vorher alles stimmt ich muss nie im
verein tätig und bin der kosmische ich
bin das jetzt noch hier auf freiwilliger
basis
gemäss der uno landwirt rund ein drittel
aller lebensmittel nicht auf dem teller
seit drei jahren kämpft merritt gegen
diese verschwendung an
jetzt nehmen wir viel mehr
filmaufnahmen sind in beteiligten
restaurant nicht erwünscht dieses neue
lied bringen
wg ist flüchtling kollege sein berater
des schmeckt super das minus aus
das war so glücklich sein können sich
jetzt zu und die gabe gemacht die mega
schneider unterwegs und sich weiter zu
als labour lang nicht fertig sieht denke
sie wäre ja und ich mir jetzt noch mal
massiv positiv überrascht aber ich
glaube also das dann wirklich so dass
global suchen dank passiert plötzlich
komplett verantwortungsvoll umgehen als
natürlicher ressourcen quartieren -
bietet und kalender so positiv gesehen
ist das eine widmann leiter der
staatlichen us tour so vieles gelungen